how do you raise capital from investors
how do you raise finance as an
entrepreneur to put that money towards
your property deals well in this video
i'm going to be giving you some really
useful tips and strategies and
techniques to how to raise finance from
investors i've personally raised
millions of pounds in finance which i've
put into my property investment deals
and after watching this video hopefully
you'll be able to do the same thing too
so first thing is structuring the deal
right
if you're trying to raise money but you
don't know how it's going to be
structured
you haven't got the right contracts you
don't know how the company's going to be
structured you're kind of on to a losing
battle because even if you go out there
like a madman pitching this deal telling
everybody you're looking for money
really really networking hard even if
someone comes to you and says i'm
interested i've got a hundred grand
what's next you're gonna be like uh uh
uh you don't know what's next so you do
need to get to the point whereby you
actually understand how to understand
how the structure is gonna be now
there's different ways you can structure
it number one is you can do it as a
straightforward loan so it can be a loan
agreement from an angel investor whereby
they can invest and you can give them a
fixed return this is a really
straightforward way to raise money um
what you need to think about though is
if you're going to raise money and it's
going to be a loan from an investor how
are you going to pay them back you need
to make sure that the deal is a good
deal it's got a lot of profit in it also
are you going to be able to give them a
charge on the property
or are you also going to need a mortgage
because if you're getting a mortgage on
a property you try and get the
difference
the mortgage company ain't going to be
happy if they're not first if they
haven't got a first charge so is it a
loan
if so is it a secured loan or an
unsecured loan what is the actual offer
to the investor or is it going to be a
joint venture now a joint venture is
just a case of they're putting the money
in and then you're going to split the
profits maybe you can split the profits
50 50. in which case how is it going to
be structured you could set it up in a
company where you could say look we're
going to set up a company together
you're going to have 50 ownership to the
company i'm going to have 50 ownership
you're going to put 100 grand in
i'm then going to use that 100 grand to
buy a property to fix it up to sell it
and then the whatever the profit we we
make the company will then divvy that up
50 50. if you're gonna do that what
security has the investor got usually
when they put the money into the company
that would be a director's loan or you
might have a shares and b shares with
the company so you just need to make
sure that when you're pitching this it's
not just about the deal the deal being
good it's also about the deal being well
structured so that it's safe and secure
for the investor so that's the very
first thing to think about before
raising capital and before trying to
raise finance from investors next thing
once you've got that set up you've got
your deal you've thought about the
structure you've got a good structure
set up which is fair and secure for the
investor next thing you need to do is
before going crazy on social media and
running your mouth everywhere and trying
to pitch everybody for deals i would
suggest
contact some of your friends and family
that you know or you suspect have got
money this is genius now because rather
than actually asking them for money
should never do that
because it's awkward if they're your
friend or your mom
and you go hey mom um
i've got this deal um could you give me
a hundred grand it's awkward because if
she says no
she might fear that it would damage your
relationship if she says yes
she might be it's just a bit awkward
asking for money so here's what you do
instead you contact your friends and
your family and your loved ones that you
know what you think or you suspect might
have money and you ask them for their
advice so you say hey
auntie hey uncle hey friends hey bob
next door
cat i've got this deal that i'm working
on at the moment and i'm i'm just
structuring everything and i'd really
love to get your opinion would it be
possible that i could meet you for a
coffee and i can share the deal with you
and then maybe you can just let me know
if you've got any advice or any pointers
because i really value your advice
who's gonna say no to that right
your mom or whoever will be like yeah
sure thing now this is not being
manipulative by the way this is just
making it easy for them
to walk away from the deal because if
you say to them hey i've got this deal
do you want to invest it's awkward but
if you say hey i've got this deal i'd
love to talk to you about it get your
advice then what you do is you show them
the deal you show them how freaking
amazing it is and go look it's gonna
make this much money you show them and
hopefully they'll be impressed and then
you say also
here's how we're gonna be structuring it
i'm actually looking for a joint venture
partner i'm looking for someone to put a
hundred grand in this is how we're going
to be structuring it do you think that
seems fair okay cool and then you can
say well look if you know anybody that
you think might be able to be a suitable
joint venture partner or an investor um
you know do let me know because i am
looking for an investor
that's it
nothing else
if they don't bite if they don't go well
you know what
we could be interested then they're not
interested so you never had to ask in
the first place just leave it move on
once you've exhausted your friends and
family and you've spoken to them if no
one's interested hopefully they will be
that's when you can start their
networking going on social media talking
about the deal be careful of not posting
specifics when you're posting on social
media it's against the fca regulations
for you to post a deal and say i'm
guaranteeing to offer x percent you
can't do that but what you can do is you
can post the deal and just say hey i've
got this deal i'm looking for partners
if anyone's interested dm me we could
have a chat you can go to networking
events and you can normally when you go
to a lot of networking events if it's a
specific business networking event
opportunity you usually have like 60
seconds to stand up and just pitch your
business so you can stand up and say hey
i've just secured a property which we're
going to be splitting into four flats
it's got 100 000 pounds profit i'm
currently looking for a partner with
somebody that's got some capital if you
know anybody come and see me in the
break
easy right this is how you do it another
thing i want to say on social media as
well the final point is build your brand
on social media every time you do a deal
every time you even view a house every
time you do anything
that shows that you're in the game
you're in the business you're getting
results post it on social media share
your journey and then all of your
contacts will be like oh this person is
doing deals this person's doing well
never grumble
don't [ __ ] online about oh i hate the
prime minister and [ __ ] and go on about
how hard life is and how depressed you
are because if you do that what's going
to happen is you're going to be
repulsing your potential future
investors so this is not about betraying
a fake life or fake it till you make it
this is about build your brand and show
people what you're doing to build up
your reputation
get good deals structure it right and
that hopefully was a useful video
[Music]
you